[Musica]
sono una persona felice a gesù sto
quadrato maledetto sono fuoco se sarà
meglio non a fuoco in questo caso
probabile bene i ragazzi
questo nuovo video si mi piace quando la
vita vale il verso giusto
sempre positivi è positivismo ah che bel
blog
vabbè da iniziamo che sono sempre un
trick bait che purtroppo non lo è ma è
una cavolata adesso vi spiego birdie
ragazzi venuti questo video sono fa vj
ero famiglia je suis famiglie
vorrei spiegare un attimo la sito una
cosa un posto imbarazzante per uno dice
cosa cosa hai fatto hai tirato una
testata al mobile fortissimo no
voi sapete che io ho un po di me in
faccia cioè non può un sacco ecco quello
è un problema perché quando mi faccio la
barba mi taglio sempre non come gli emo
non lo faccio apposta lo faccia
accidentalmente vorrei evitare per
questo motivo i lei che ho in faccia
molto presto
non tutti però un po se ne andranno via
almeno quelli in modo che non avrò più
così tanto ti potrò 4 rileggo ecco cosa
è successo sono andato a togliermi uno
che stava qua non so se avete notato
nell'ultimo periodo
nell'ultima settimana io ho avuto
cerotto gigantesco proprio nel video che
ha viralizzato di più a rate che culo
perché era andato a togliermi il neo e
poi mi hanno messo il cerotto ovviamente
perché quando lo togli si deve
rimarginare la ferita poi a posto il
dottore mi ha detto ascolta non ti
toccare perché il cerotto lì non ti
toccare per una settimana poi vengo
perché hanno messi punti poi mi vieni a
toglierti punti io mi sono tolto il
cerotto tutti i giorni melo disinfettato
come un deficiente perché non avevo
capito pensavo di darmelo disinfettanti
sono andato una settimana dopo dal
dottore del dottore mi ha detto ehi tu
mi sa che hai dei problemi di testa e
quindi tela fascio perché non dovevo
farlo devo stare fermo allora che cosa
ha fatto mi ha tolto i punti ovviamente
la ferita si è riaperta perché io
continuavo
infettarono a quando non dovevo quindi
non le davo tempo di rimarginarsi allora
mi ha rimesso i punti mi ha rifatto
l'operazione mi ha rimesso i punti mi ha
messo il cerotto e nonostante il cerotto
mi ha fasciato tutta la testa come
vedete nella serie adesso puoi toccarti
manco se vuoi te la prendi nel dell'età
e ti sta pure bene e niente quindi è
quasi una settimana che ho questa cosa
qua ho già registrato i video quindi non
vi preoccupate non mi vedrete nel video
conciato così come se stessimo rendo
però devo tenere questa cosa che mi da
un prurito e mi vorrei scorticare il
cervello ed è veramente scomoda nel
mentre che facevo questa cosa mi ha
chiamato il dottore per sapere come
stavo dottore sto veramente la schifo
però gli ho detto che sto bene qui ho
dovuto tenere questa cosa tutta la
settimana e ho voluto sfruttare diciamo
questa cosa qua per reaction dei miei
amici come i miei amici hanno reagito
alla mia
[Musica]
[Risate]
ero combattuto contro un mammut
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quindi oggi è l'ultimo giorno insomma lo
tolgo è stato bello non è vero non lo è
stato per niente
spero che non mi debbano lasciare così
ogni volta mi tolgono poi piccolo e così
è minuscolo però mi hanno fasciato manco
stessimo rendo va beh spero mi sia
piaciuto appello avere degli amici in
momenti così difficili grazie di starmi
accanto
siete fantastici premi sia piaciuto
quando mi piace ricordatevi trovate
sempre la positività nelle cose che
succedono anche ai tempi quando mi ero
fasciato il braccio ci giocavo su di
brutto perché chi se ne frega
viva la vita non tirate testate però il
mobile che sono finite le cose i ragazzi
vi è piaciuta momento vi piace quelli
sociali nell'adottare sitzia senato da
qualsiasi scrivetevi noi ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo io non oso pensare come
saranno i miei capelli quando mi toglie
lo sta roba da ragazzi
[Musica]